it's great to welcome to the program
today democratic congressman jamie
raskin who represents maryland's 8th
congressional district was the lead
house manager in the second impeachment
trial of former president donald trump
congressman it's so great to have you on
i i'm delighted to be with you david
thank you for having me so okay to start
with what we're going to have starting
with in prime time on june 9th
uh these public hearings related to the
january 6 committee
and there are sort of two opposing
forces here there's one side yourself
included who have been saying what's
going to be revealed during those
hearings is going to be
mind-blowing that's my term not
necessarily a term that you have used
the other side is this feeling that
nothing's really going to happen
nobody's ultimately going to be held
accountable for what happened
what can you say to those in my audience
who are in that ladder group who are
concerned about lack of accountability
um well
this is all part of the process of
making
um
the events of january 6th visible
comprehensible to people and making them
the basis of real accountability now
some of that accountability is legal
accountability uh and that's really
within the realm of the department of
justice
which has brought more than 800
prosecutions in the most sweeping
investigation in the history of the doj
obviously we're all on the edge of our
seats to see if they're going to work
their way all the way up to the top or
whether uh trump as uh a kind of mob
boss is able to insulate himself with
several uh layers of buffer between him
and the criminal actions and the legal
consequences of those actions but i do
think that the investigation is
proceeding a pace and they're working
their way up the way that a lot of
organized crime investigations
work their way up uh the latter but then
there's there's public and political
accountability and that's really what
the january six select committee is all
about i mean under house resolution 503
our job is to report to congress and to
the american people about what happened
on january 6 and what were the causes
behind it and then to make
recommendations about how to fortify our
institutions going forward
do you expect some of your colleagues in
the house may have legal liability
well
um
you know
first of all that again that's not
really our role in other words we're
understanding we are turning and we're
turning over evidence of people who
are
uh
of congress because
they refuse to participate for example
um
dan scavino and peter navarro
you know they never
gave a single document to the committee
they never spent one minute testifying
they just blew us off
um
mark meadows was kind of one foot in and
one foot out doing the hokey pokey gave
us some stuff and then trump got mad
withdrew
um
you know steve bannon's blown us off
we've turned all of that information
over to the department of justice we've
voted told them in contempt and now it's
up to the executive branch and the doj
to enforce that
in terms of evidence of other crimes
we're
in the process of laying them out there
um
and you know in the john eastman
litigation when uh judge carter
was dealing with eastman's
claim that he was somehow covered by
attorney-client privilege
um
the judge asked the question well was
there an attorney client of privilege
was it waived and um
does it even apply if it existed because
of
the crime fraud exception and we've said
there was no attorney-client privilege
if there was it was waived and
you know
in any event
it doesn't apply because all of these
crimes were committed and we set them
forth and judge carter basically adopted
what we had to say so we've not been shy
about
setting forth statutory uh offenses um
but look
as much as we all would like to see
donald trump and
uh others in his uh
inner echelon
uh held legally accountable
far more important is whether or not we
can solidify our democratic institutions
and keep
uh the engines of democracy turning i
mean that's just so much more important
than you know how donald trump
spends the remaining years of his life
whether it's behind bars or somewhere
else i care a lot more about whether or
not we are going to be able to bequeath
the democracy a working functional
democracy to our children and our
grandchildren because the autocrats the
dictators the despots are on the march
all over the world and
from
moscow to mar-a-lago they're working to
undermine democratic process
and to drain
life from our institutions and we've got
to make sure we've got something to give
our kids yeah to that end i mean it
seems very clear that at least to some
degree some of the people who are trying
to avoid coming before your committee
are trying to run out the clock knowing
that if republicans take the house in
november and are sworn in in january
this committee is is essentially over is
your plan to be done
long before that in order to prevent an
interruption before you're done with
your work as a result of the election
[Music]
to have our hearings begin tonight uh
there will be six hearings uh at least
that take place in the month of june um
there will be um
perhaps another hearing or two in the
future to deliver the recommendations of
the committee and there will be a report
and we're hoping to have all of that
done
um early in the fall
uh you know it's not just our committee
that ends with this congress everything
ends with this congress because
house of representatives
uh unlike the senate
is a new
newly constituted body every two years
you know we come to the end of the
congress and then there's a new congress
that forms the senate because of the
overlapping nature of their terms is a
continuing body they only lose one-third
of their members
or one-third of their members are up for
re-election whereas our entire body's up
for re-election we adopt new rules at
the beginning of the house and so on so
it's not any kind of strategic political
calculus it's just that we've got to get
this done before uh this session of
congress ends okay when it comes to gun
safety there have been some of your
colleagues who have said something feels
different this time we've seen a couple
of republicans
including adam kinzinger and uh
congressman jacobs who have said i
actually have a new position when it
comes to either an assault weapons ban
or ar-15
there's something that that might be a
little bit different this time but we've
seen this cycle for a long time which is
there's a mass shooting everybody says
we must do something republicans come in
and say oh yeah sure but that can
include actually dealing with gun safety
and then there's no major shooting in
the news for a couple of weeks and
nothing happens and it's rinse repeat
for year after year after year is your
genuine opinion that this is going to be
that same cycle or that maybe something
will be different this time
well
you know my my colleagues senior to me
believe it is going to be the exact same
thing it's been before because the nra
exerts such a stranglehold over
the gop and
in the final analysis as they will
refuse to move uh on the other hand um
yeah i'm of the mind that uh
the republicans think that they are in
a place where they can actually
seize control of the house and the
senate and they can
win these elections um you know they've
obviously been uh vilifying and
demonizing joe biden and
uh yet they're starting to realize that
the public is overwhelmingly against
them on all the big issues i mean you
know they are the dog that caught the
car when it comes to destroying road
versus wade in the constitutional right
to privacy so that creates uh explosive
political conditions where the women of
america can turn all math against the
gop and what they've done to destroy
women's reproductive freedom um
similarly
uh the
the gun violence is so out of control
and so
dangerous and frightening to people
that there could they could experience a
similar
[Music]
earthquake with young people in america
who just say enough is enough and
the young people
who
really rocked american politics from
parkland florida
with the march for our lives
are
organizing another march
and people are saying that hundreds of
thousands or maybe even a million people
could come to washington um so i think
that the gop may have the sense
that uh their big chance to do what they
really care about most which is taking
power
could all be squandered
because of the recklessness of their
policies and so that would argue that
they might try to do something
so that they're not so clearly the party
that is tagged with all these massacres
one of my constituents wrote me the
other day with the idea that the
massacres
should be named after the republican
members of congress and the senators
whose districts and states
they represent when those are the
members who are doing nothing
to
get us a universal violent criminal
background check doing nothing to
close the
uh
you know the gun show loophole the
internet loophole the private seal
loophole doing nothing uh to take
weapons of war out of the hands of 18
year olds and
um
you know essentially reduce the
slaughter which puts america into a
class completely of its own i mean you
know we're suffering uh gun casualties
20 times 25 50 times higher um than
other
industrialized countries and it's all
because you know on that note um
many of my liberal friends who are for
all sorts of different gun safety
regulations which i know you support and
which i support
also are of the mindset that they don't
love the idea of only the right wingers
having the guns and they are
increasingly seeking firearms themselves
and obtaining them almost like a race to
the bottom of sorts if you will
do
do you sympathize with that fear does
that does that make sense to you to some
degree
well
i mean the supreme court of course in
heller versus district columbia said
that the core of the individual right
under the second amendment is the right
of self-defense in your home and um
people have that right that's deeply
anchored in american culture and law
and um
so
if there are people who
uh are fearful
for that reason and they they feel that
firearms will keep them safe uh they you
know they have a right to exercise their
second amendment rights um in that way
of course the liberals in the supreme
court had advanced the traditional view
which is that uh
the the second amendment is about the
right uh to possess guns in connection
with militia service in other words you
read the prefatory clause or
well-regulated militia being necessary
of the survival of the free state
um comma in conjunction with the
operative clause the right of the people
to keep and bear arms shall not be in
french in any of it the conservative
majority won on that but even justice
scalia uh was emphatic
that
reasonable gun regulation is totally
within the contemplation of the second
amendment and you don't have to sell
assault weapons to
uh
anybody and you don't have to allow kids
to get weapons and you don't have to
allow people to take weapons into public
places um you know i i hope we have not
arrived at civil war style conditions
um but i you know i think it's perfectly
healthy for people across the political
spectrum to exercise their second
amendment rights but it's also perfectly
healthy for us to understand what second
second amendment rights really are right
and what the authority of government is
to guarantee public safety because
that's essential to the social contract
and the whole reason we get into a
social contract if you read locke and
hobbes and rousseau is that we
surrender the rights of violent
self-help
in exchange for
security in a civil society uh but the
republicans who refuse to do nothing
essentially you know give us the worst
of both worlds they compel kids to go to
school under the truancy laws under the
mandatory attendance laws but then they
leave them as sitting ducks because they
won't
do anything to
keep them safe from mass slaughter with
assault weapons
congressman last thing i want to ask you
about and i know our time is is not
unlimited i'm not an advocate of a
primary challenge to joe biden i think
if joe biden decides to run for
re-election that he should be the
democratic nominee from a strategic
point of view that being said when
people say to me
david is there anyone you think would be
interesting to see as the democratic
nominee to be totally honest i think of
you i think of john ossoff i think john
ossoff would be very interesting i know
that it would be
a crazy thing to ask you if it's
something you think about thinking about
you would never answer it it would be
inappropriate it would be a crazy thing
to ask but my more specific question is
one of the things i do think is i think
that
unfortunately because of anti-semitism
on both the right and some on the left
i think jewish presidential candidates
would still struggle because of
anti-semitism what's your opinion about
that issue in america right now
i hadn't really thought that through
david uh well let me see um and i i
wonder if you're asking me this because
i i happen to be in new hampshire
campaigning for my friends uh chris
pappas and annie kuster and for senator
maggie hassan uh but um
you know
look
i think it's really important for the
young people of america to understand
and the kids of america to understand
despite what they might see on the
internet and despite what they might
hear from some people in public office
we are not a racist country we are not
an anti-semitic country we are not a
sexist misogynistic
country we are not an immigrant fashion
country and
um i believe uh so much in you know what
tom payne saw when he got to america i
mean he said this country
could become an asylum for humanity not
an insane asylum mind you but it could
become a place of refuge for people
fleeing from every form of political
religious economic repression and
discrimination on earth
and i think despite what we've lived
with through donald trump and the proud
boys and the oath keepers and the
militia groups and the three percenters
and despite all of the divisiveness and
the polarization i still believe we are
the world's greatest multi-racial
multi-religious multi-ethnic
constitutional democracy and the sky's
the limit for what we can make happen
for our people once we fight off all of
these authoritarian racist attacks
on our country so
um
you know there there would be a lot of
reasons that i wouldn't run for
president but being jewish would not be
one of them
congressman jamie raskin i really
appreciate your time and we're going to
be watching uh next week as the hearings
start very closely thank you so much
thanks so much for having me david